14 يوما مضى على زلزال تركيا وسوريا الذي
قتل ما يزيد على 45 الف شخص تعمل تركيا
اعلى معاينه الاضرار سريعا واعاده اعمار
مدن الجنوب بعد زلزال الذي شرد اكثر من
مليوني شخص ولكن التكلفه باهضه نتحدث عن
عشرات المليارات من الدولارات يرجح ان
تكون اكبر مجهودات لاعاده الاعمار في
تركيا منذ تاسيس الجمهوريه عام 1923 حيث
نصف المباني البالغ عددها نحو ثلاثه ونصف
المليون مبنى في المناطق المتضرره قد
تحتاج الى الهدم الكارثه شردت جزءا كبيرا
من القوى العامله في البلاد مع مخاوف
منطقيه لعدم عوده الايدي الماهره لاهم
المناطق الصناعيه في البلاد بعد عوده
الاستقرار الاثار الاقتصاديه المحتمله
للزلزال في تركيا قد تؤدي الى خساره تصل
الى
واحد اجمالي البلاد هذا العام كل ذلك بحسب
البنك الاوروبي للتنميه واعاده الاعمار
بالارقام خسائر زلازل العالم الابرز عبر
التاريخ مع علاء سرحان
مليار دولار هي حصيله الاضرار الاقتصاديه
لزلزال الذي ضرب لوس انجلوس عام
1994 ويعتبر احد اكثر الكوارث الطبيعيه
تكلفه في تاريخ الولايات المتحده في الصين
85 مليار دولار هو حجم الاضرار الاقتصاديه
التي نتجت عن زلزال عام 2008 100 مليار
دولار اجمالي الخسائر الاقتصاديه الناجمه
عن زلزال كوبي المدمر في اليابان عام
مليارات دولار هي قيمه الخسائر الاقتصاديه
الناجمه عن زلزال وتسونامي توهوكو في
اليابان 2011 وكارثه مفاعل بوكوتشينه التي
اعقبتهما وهو الاسوا في هذه القائمه اما
في تركيا 84 مليار دولار هو حجم الخسائر
الاقتصاديه المتوقعه لزلزال السادس من
فبراير وهو ما يعادل نحو 10% من اقتصاد
البلاد في عام 2022
[موسيقى]
من المبكر انه نعرف حقا ايش قد راح تكلف
هذه الخسائر على تركيا
طيب اليوم سمر امام كل هذه التبعات التي
لحقت بالزلزال ومن بينها التبعات
الاقتصاديه اذا ما دخلنا اكثر بالتفاصيل
وتحدثنا عن حياه الفرد المواطن التركي كيف
سيتاثر بعد هذه الكارثه مبدئيا طبعا عندك
اول شيء السياحه يعني من الاشياء التي
تاثرت يعني في اشخاص انا اعرف اشخاص
كنسلوا رحلتهم احنا كان عندنا عطله قبل
هذا الاسبوع اللي فات للاولاد كنسلوا بعض
الاشخاص كنسلوا رحالهم الى تركيا لانه حتى
لو كانت في مناطق بعيده بعدها عندك تروما
مالك نفس انت تروحي وتنبسطين وفي ناس بنفس
هذا البلد عندهم مشاكل صحيح بعدين عندك
مثلا حتى تحدثت مع احدى شركات الطيران
قالوا انه لاحظوا في كانسليشن على الرحلات
بس وفي الغاء وفي طلب عوده يعني صار اللي
قصروا اجازاتهم اللي كانوا هناك موجودين
اوريدي قصروا ايضا عندك شيء مهم انه اللي
صار مثلا لنفترض لناخذ اليابان مثلا في
المنطقه اللي صار فيها الزلزال عام 2011
توهوكو اللي هي طبعا جزء منها
هذه المنطقه لما تاثرت بالزلزال عام 2011
الحكومه خصصت خلال عشر سنين الف فقط 300
مليار دولار لاعاده الاعمار بنايات كلها
مقاومه للزلزال
تسع درجات شوارع جديده بس يقول الخبراء
هناك انه الاجيال الجديده الاجيال الاصغر
هجره المنطقه ولم تعد اليها مره اخرى مثل
ما قلنا قبل شويه يصير عندهم مثل تروما او
رد فعل ويدورون على مناطق اكثر امانه يعني
انه تكلفه بناء مباني مقاومه للزلزال
باهظه جدا صحيح وكم سنه كمان يتطلبها
اعاده الاعمال لانهاء كل هذه المنطقه
اعماريا عندك المشكله اليوم اللي يتخوف من
الورد بانك او البنك الدولي اللي جمع
تقريبا ثلاثه الى اربعه مليار دولار
لاعاده الاعمار يتخوف من مساله الفساد
الاداريه ومساله يعني اللي يصير الاختلاس
وغيرها فالمفروض انه هذه الامور طبعا
تتطلب بهاي المنطقه خصوصا قد ياخذ الامر
يعني ابته عشر سنين يعني اللي خرب بخمسه
وسبعين ثانيه ممكن يتطلب الامر عشر سنوات
او اكثر لاعاده الاعمار اذا هذا الكلام ما
تم وصلت المساعدات فعلا وصلت المخصصات
فعلا وما صار هناك في مشاكل فساد اداري
وغيرها وهي تركيا هذا الشيء مثل ما قلنا
قبل شويه حياثر على ميزانها على الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي قد يكلفه 10% من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي طبعا لا ننسى ان تركيا
هاي الفتره كلها كان عندها مشاكل في
التضخم مشاكل في انخفاض
العمله التركيه وانهيارها فكل هذه المسائل
الاخرى ستضيف المزيد من الاعباء على
الاقتصاد التركي وايضا مثل ما قلنا مساله
السياحه حتتاثر كثيرا بحسب الخبراء لان
الاشخاص اللي صار عندهم هاي التروما يعني
مثل ما تاثرت باليابان تسونامي وتايلند
تاثرت فتره لتعافت وعاده الاشخاص مره اخرى
الى السياحه في تلك المنطقه احنا بنشكرك
جزيل الشكر شكرا جزيلا شكرا والله ان شاء
الله يعني يساعد الناس
شكرا جزيلا